i was going to say so what um
drove your passion to this
or where's the origins of all this
passion coming from well you know i'll
be i'll be honest with you it didn't
start with passion as much as it did
with anger
so we've heard of human trafficking in
other countries but is it happening in
our own backyard
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live it's a show where we
use the light of christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today we're excited about this show but
before we get into it we just want to
shout out our patreons and those who
donate through our website and also
people who buy our little light studios
or i should say light wear t-shirts
thank you so much for your support
that's really the reason why we're able
to continue with the show and we see in
the comment section how much of a
blessing it's been so thank you for
watching and supporting little light
studios led live
today we have alex on the show with us
thank you for for being here you know a
lot of times we hear stories um kind of
so far removed like in other places in
the world little do we know that those
same things tragedies and or things that
are so out of this world so to speak can
be happening right here on our soil so
um i got to hear a little bit of your
story and i'm just really excited to
hear about where you started where you
are now and of course the future because
there's things that we can do right here
to impact not just our world but the
world at large so let's get started with
um what you're into it right now yeah
well i i would say that you know um i
started off just i guess like most
people
i mean we all know that there's problems
in our country and where we're at
there's problems in first world
countries right we're not immune just
because we're in a better financial
situation um but i was still of
the mindset that primarily certain
things only happen or primarily happen
within you know third world countries or
wherever there's poverty and destitution
all those kinds of things and corruption
and whatnot and so kind of i think
my story started uh because of that
stark reality of a third world country
situation waking me up to begin
searching for it in other places and
then i discovered oh wow it's actually
in a whole lot more places than than i
had thought
so we're kind of tiptoeing around here
but i forgot to mention the main topic
for today is about human trafficking
right so that's the big uh tragedy so to
speak of what we're talking about where
it's not just
you know in other countries it's
happening right here in the states right
right
um and when it comes to human
trafficking i think a lot of us have
kind of maybe
i mean
i don't mean in an insulting way we have
a very kind of limited view of what that
is and to me
over the the years of experience it's
kind of presented itself as more as the
tip of the iceberg
of a lot of more underlying issues um
you know we we talk about a history of
slavery in this country but in reality
it still exists it just takes different
forms and affects different types of
people and and if we think about it if
we you know
slavery is in many ways and even
prostitution which is kind of one of the
aspects of slavery that we're going to
talk about is they're both
the world's oldest businesses
if you think about they're
long-standing they've always had
somebody that's been you know pushing
these types of industries forward uh
there's never a point in in world's
history where these haven't existed
uh where people haven't been taken
advantage of you know for somebody
else's gain yeah and so it's you know
it's a sad reality of a world that's
fallen into sin
um but i think you know when we just
let's take the term trafficking right
like human trafficking the word
trafficking itself is the movement or
illegal movement of of
objects or goods right it could be
cross-border could be noticed from from
place a to place b and then you add
human to it and it's basically treating
the human as a good
right that's implicit within the the
term human trafficking you're now
treating a human being as if they were
good
and and we see that in in the bible as
well we see that in revelation 18. if
you look in revelation 18 it gives you
this list uh from 11 to 13 of all of the
things that that it's that these
merchants of the earth are dealing in
you know they're dealing in gold and in
silver and oil and wine and cattle and
then it says in in souls of men right
and slaves and souls of men
and so a lot of people will say well
they're dealing in this and that and the
way that i look at it is a little bit
differently i'm seeing it that they're
dealing with people as if they were
cattle or gold or silver or whatever
something that is just a commodity that
can be exchanged it doesn't have any
inherent value beyond what you can gain
on the on the market
um
and that's why i think uh you know when
we talk about kind of looking at it from
a bigger perspective which i hope to do
um it's going to add a level of
resolution that i think god brings to
the picture that that merely working for
organizations like i did and and trying
to rescue people while noble as it is
adds a different element to that because
what god does in giving his son is he
pays a price that nobody can pay and
when you pay a price that nobody else
can pay you're in essence you're off
market because then nobody can trade you
anymore
and so obviously that's that's a deep
concept that kind of you know we can
flesh out a little bit later in the
conversation but but yeah i i was
ignorant of a lot of things and and it's
not
it's not wrong to be ignorant it's wrong
to remain ignorant yes
and so a lot of us we start in a place
where we we're just not exposed to
things
and so it took a pretty drastic
situation to kind of wake me up to to
what was going on okay well let's get it
oh good i was going to say so what um
drove your passion to this
or where's the origins of all this
passion coming from well you know i'll
be i'll be honest with you it didn't
start with passion as much as it did
with anger
and and and you know and i look at
even god in in the bible where there are
certain times where
i guess you could say passion was
you know was born from a righteous anger
right people calling out to him crying
out i heard the cry of my people right
you know and so it's it's a deliverance
it's like kind of like the zeal to to
rescue those that are that are crying
out because they're in trouble
and so i think that you know the
situation that put me in that was i was
living with a friend of mine in in kenya
back in 2009
and he
he wanted um at one point in time to
kind of working on a project but he had
a friend in sudan
south sudan
and um he was a pastor he was taking
care of a church that he and his
brothers
um my friend um
he was american but he his parents were
missionaries in africa he and his
brothers had he and his brother and his
cousin had built kind of like this
school and this pastor sudanese pastor
was taking care of it pastor julius
for a number of years and and he didn't
even have a house to live in so he's
like man i need to build this guy a
house and i was like sure whatever you
want man let's go build this guy house
and uh just the way getting to sudan was
already treacherous it would take us
five days driving to go from where we
were in kenya to south sudan near the
border with the drc democratic republic
of the congo it's right on the border
there in a small village called karika
and uh
i think three of the days would have
been no roads or
roads that you can barely call roads
yeah uh potholes that can swallow tanks
if you think potholes here are a problem
quite literally just areas of road
washed out bridge is gone just just very
very difficult
kenya is easy to go through but once you
reach sudan because of its situation
of
kind of its split south of north sudan
during this time they were
they had just kind of put a ceasefire to
their civil war
and they were given time to kind of
govern themselves um
to see whether south sudan would remain
separate from north sudan which was
primarily muslim and then in the south
you had your christians animists and
traditional
kind of religions and so
we needed to go there and there was an
area between south sudan and kenya that
was kind of a dmz demilitarized zone
this is no man's land um
if you guys ever grew up watching looney
tunes yeah yeah you know like the road
runner yeah wiley coyote like you go
through these areas where there's like
cliffs and he's always like on top of
the cliff with like the perfect ambush
spot to drop a rock or some type of
thing like this is kind of that area in
real life it's
it's a desert area um
i mean there's not huge cliffs but
there's tall enough cliffs there's lots
of rocks lots of areas to hide behind a
lot of you know
uh so it's like the perfect ambush spot
and it was not controlled by either the
sudanese or or the kenyan side it's just
the area and dispute for a number of
years i remember how long but
significant amount of time
and uh we decided that we needed to go
anyway and we went on a pickup truck so
there was five of us that went
um
we took some locals with us to help us
build you know who were familiar with
with the building style of that that
area we took them with us so we could
have extra help and
a reporter with us as well from nairobi
and uh the five of us were gonna go on a
pickup truck three in the back sitting
on our things and then two people in the
cabin and so you realize you you don't
wanna go through that area with a pile
of construction goods with people
sitting on top of it that could fall off
fairly easily you can't really just gun
it through that area and we know that
there were raiding tribes
people were just looking for an
opportunity to
you know a lot of cattle herders and
things like that and so
leading up to this time we decided that
we're going to go in three days because
we already set off
and before we got there um
like two or three days before we got
there there was a raid in the dmz
of
a a cattle herder tribe
against another tribe village and there
were some military kenyan military that
were stationed in that place and they
were caught up in the raid and the
locals said that some of them were
killed the news official media says
nobody was killed they were just injured
but regardless of what happened
within that two or three day period of
time the kenyan military mobilized a
vast portion of their military into the
dmz and that 25 kilometers which had
been undisputed
for so long now became one kilometer and
our entire drive there was kenyan
soldiers with their tents and their
tanks and their jeeps and all that kinds
of stuff like waving us safely because
they even created a road
right they even created a road through
most of that area and so here we were
wondering how are we going to get to
this pastor to build him a house
and then you know with our little faith
and our weak prayers you know
god mobilized
like i don't know what percentage but
you know a good percentage of the kenyan
military into this area that they would
just nobody never considered it a
priority until two days before we were
supposed to leave and make it to sudan
and so it was already an answer to kind
of showing the power of prayer and that
god can move armies like we do we think
about like you know we read in the old
testament like god moves armies like god
you know sets up kings and brings them
down and we just don't see that
sometimes and we kind of question was
that still true and you know it's
amazing that even at that time it didn't
strike us only after the fact wait a
second
did god just move a nation's military
just to get us to to build a path a
house for pastor julius and you know and
so there was already god's hands and and
and the beginnings of him showing us
that that there is a conflict and that
he has power within that if
we are actually calling on him to
to intervene
um
we make it to sudan we're building a
house for pastor julius there's you know
there's some locals that also came from
from karika to help us you know work on
a daily basis and i became friends with
one of the guys and there were kids
playing there obviously there's a
there's a school that was there built
for 400 600 kids
and um
no men i mean there's very few men
because of the war a lot of the men
leave a lot of the fathers leave so
these kids were just taken care of by
their mothers
and many of them um
would go to other countries or they
would go to juba the capital of south
sudan
and
they would come back some would come
back a couple couple months some would
come back six months most of them would
actually never come back there was lots
of stories of people who would just
start other families elsewhere they'd
just marry somebody else and start
families and never send anything back
and uh you know just lots of kids
running around
there's a few men not to say that they
weren't they were known but there's
there's very few men
and uh there was this one girl that
caught my attention um my friend would
always tease her just because she would
get so irritated easily for you know we
were like what's wrong with her like you
know
but when i kind of noticed a pattern
that whenever she would start playing
with kids like if it was a girl like
they were playing tag for instance it
was a girl that was chasing her it was
just all normal right but if a boy
started chasing her she'd also like turn
aggressive she'd you know pick up stuff
and start throwing it at him and like or
you know like pulling his shirt or
things like that i'm just like okay you
know once or twice you think about but
then like day after day you're kind of
like why did you keep on you just
noticed the pattern
and one day i didn't see her when i
didn't see her play
and so i asked one of the local guys to
remember his name but he was helping me
make cement that day
and uh
church member and he's like i asked him
like so where's you know crazy girl i
called her crazy girl i didn't think
anything of it at the time and she's
like oh he's like oh she's with her
husband all right dude that's that's a
dumb joke and he's like
i'm not joking and this is a child
you're she's eight years old
she's eight years is with her husband
with her husband that sentence isn't
even it doesn't it didn't register with
him that's why i thought he was joking
and how old is her husband i don't
remember it was somewhere in the late
30s early 40s so that's around 40 years
old you know plus or minus a couple
years and how did he say this
oh she's with her husband it sounded
like
sad in a way but like
as if i may be desensitized to the fact
that it was normal
and also
maybe that they couldn't there's nothing
they could do about it
wow and so her her mother decided to
sell her
and so you know it's just like what do
you do her mom decides to sell her to
this guy so is this like legal there i
mean it's not that it's legal there's no
there's no one to enforce it like the
countries and complete upheaval during
this time you know the spla the sudanese
people liberation army are just creating
havoc they find you know they have their
own power and whatever and they're just
they're not going to come and enforce
this kind of thing you know so whether i
i'm i'm guessing it wasn't within their
law to accept eight-year-old marriages
but
who's going to do anything about it in
the middle of the jungle so what leads
up to that is it that the mother is
destitute and it's like yeah she needs
money for food to feed the rest of her
family or is it that men are coming and
it's like you take this money or i'll
take your daughter by force no no i i
think you know i mean there are
situations like that where people will
come and they'll demand like that's
that's probably more the case so in
thailand uh but in this particular
situation um it was just her her father
had left this this woman's husband had
left and he had never come back and they
assumed that he just started another
family somewhere else and that he was
never going to come back he was never
going to send money back and she didn't
work
so it's kind of like
right how do i
how do i survive
and so you know there was a man
supposedly who was willing to you know
give her some money or keep her or
sustain her life you know um
if he if she was willing to give up her
daughter and and uh i guess that's the
deal that she made so
do you know how much is like the average
cost or is it usually money is it
trading like i'll give you i'll be
honest with you like i my my best guess
and it could happen one of two ways it
could either happen with a large sump
large lump of money some of money or it
could happen
as i
i assumed that it would be like i will
be kind of like not necessarily your
husband but i will be kind of like that
man that takes care of you for a while
and your sugar daddy or something
well in a sense because like her husband
left and so she she lost her the basis
of her
sustenance right
and so
sometimes some people are short-sighted
and they'll be like yeah just give me
some money right now but there are times
where it's kind of like hey just take
care of me for a consistent basis and
you can have my daughter right you pay
me and she stays
with you
and and so the reason
you know the reason that that she didn't
come to play with the other kids that
morning was because
you know it's the middle of jungle
there's there's
you know
there's
not a lot there and so he basically
the guy told me that he just uses soap
and water and and
for lack of a better term rapes her and
in the morning she doesn't get up to
play um
you know she's in too much pain she's
obviously she's eight years old oh my
goodness that's infuriating and like
that's that's the thing was that you
know i i didn't have time to ask
questions like how much did he pay or
what did he do or whatever like for me
like the moment that i found out that
that was the reality like honestly
i wanted to kill the guy
i just i wanted to get up i was like
just the first question that i wanted to
ask was where does he live
where does he live you're in a tough
spot so you all are foreigners in this
yeah you get hit with this information
what's your response well you know
we we went through a lot of tribal a lot
of trouble just to get a knife into the
country
we we we we wrapped because we needed a
knife
you know all of us we're we're outdoor
guys we're living in in the jungle like
we're not going to the jungle without at
least a knife and so the way that we
even got across the border is we took
knives we wrapped them in socks and we
put them in the undercarriage of our car
and attached them we taped them to like
the tubing
like in our car because they check
everything why because we are not
sudanese we don't look sudanese and with
with as many things that that have
happened there with as many foreign
countries that have taken advantage of
them like every white person that comes
into that country is suspect
right there was stories of people who
just one guy who went to visit and he
took a river rock
right and and that because he just like
liked the river rock and they were like
no you're stealing minerals from us
because they don't know some of them
just they don't know and they just
they assume that that we're there to
take advantage of them and so this is in
the back of my mind and i'm like i
cannot stir trouble here
but i cannot i cannot like just go and
like break this guy's legs to make
myself feel better or whatever this is
this is a bad idea and i was not going
to tell my friend because i know that he
would not have this level of
self-control that i was trying to
wrestle this is not an isolated
situation it's not an isolated situation
okay and so it's kind of like
well how much more of this exists right
i mean there's a school of 600 kids
she can't be the only one
you're in a village where
where there are more kids than there are
men
right there's more kids than there are
adults
and
surely this is yeah and and you're
almost afraid to ask the question
because then what what do you do just
put yourself in a in a deeper hole of
like kind of like i can't do anything
about this
yeah but that's the good question what
did you do what what birthday well i
started i started asking questions i
started talking with with pastor julius
so i started talking with pastor julius
because i had already said that i was
gonna send his daughter
and um his adopted son to school in
uganda so there was a school right
across the border in uganda and pastor
julius's wife was going to go in and
live there as well and so i raised money
to to pay for both of them to go to
school and every year i did it i sent
them money for five years to send them
to school and so my first question right
was saying okay i'm going to send sarah
to school
right
can i send this girl to school and i
remember her name i don't even know if i
ever asked her i think i did but i can't
remember on the screen i think that's
her to be honest with you i think that's
her okay i know i had another picture
where i was sure that it was her but but
but i this is sarah
right and then this sarah this this here
sarah right so this is pastor julius's
daughter okay as pastor julius's
daughter and um
i assume that this is her because she
was always with her baby brother so
whenever she was not with her husband
she was always taking care of a baby
brother her mother would never be seen
with her baby brother it was always her
taking care of her baby brother
um
but
i said can't can't i sponsor her to go
to the school in uganda he says no you
can't
the man won't allow it and neither will
the mother
and so without the man's permission or
the mother's permission
you can't we can't do that
said oh okay so we can't get her over
the border to uganda like can we you
know
you think things like how about if i
like kidnap her right
what if i do like a salvific kidnapping
um and that just didn't seem plausible
with crossing the border not with us at
least
not with us at least
um you know a bunch of foreigners trying
to cross the border with a kid like you
would look like me
exactly right that's true um obviously
killing the guy was not an option it
would just be some way to vent anger but
not resolve anything and then put you in
greater trouble
um with god and with man right
um and imagine the impact like in the
future like what could have been done
yeah you know and it's
this is this is the weird thing
the weird thing is that you feel
helpless like hopeless like there's
nothing that i can do in this situation
but then at some point in time i think
that you have to come to the realization
that that
okay maybe that's a relevant way to feel
but maybe that's a stupid way to feel
because at the end of the day
the person who's not helpless is not
it's not you who's helpless is not you
the person who's helpless is her
like i get to go home
i get i get to at the very least still
have choice over my life and have some
level of control okay i've got
circumstances that might be against me
and you know people that try to hinder
me but i'm not controlled by somebody
that's not her situation
her situation for the rest of her life
is that man
basically you know and who knows how
long she'll live
that's that's another question like in
that type of situation how long do you
live
right
and so it's
there's some level of helplessness but
you have to basically put it on the back
shelf because you realize man that
that's
not the real helplessness
the real hopelessness and helplessness
is her situation
and the way that she's going to feel
which you can't you can't even begin to
imagine like i try to figure out like
you know there's times where i would
just go back over this event and like i
wonder what she's doing like i wonder
how she's feeling and and to be honest
with you i just
in no honest way could i say i can i can
picture that
now was it is it inappropriate for you
to have even gone and like talked to her
not even just about well i didn't i
didn't see her anymore oh
i didn't see her did you ever see her i
saw her one time i saw her one time uh
when when we finished uh pastor julius's
house and and we had a church service
right after and right after the church
service we we went back to juba was the
capital of of uh
of south sudan
and so i saw her come to the church and
and that's where i remember the picture
the last picture that i took she was
there
she was there with with all of the
church members
um
but
but yeah i i don't since that point i i
didn't that was the last time that i saw
her
she didn't show up to play with the kids
anymore after a particular day and i
don't know how long
that took but um
it's kind of fuzzy in my memory because
it's so long ago how many days was
between
that and
when we had finished pastor julius's
house
so um yeah i remember
it was it was that last picture that i
took was the last time that i that i saw
her so
did you ever meet her husband i didn't
and and i think that probably was god's
divine intervention
that as well
um that i never saw him he never came to
church he never knew obviously he wasn't
a member of the church but uh
yeah i mean other people were clearly
aware of the situation i mean because
that dude said he's yeah she's with her
yeah i mean people know a pastor julius
knew pastor julius knew he there's
nothing that he could really do about it
he seemed troubled about it as well and
um
yeah i i don't know when when when you
think about
i considered him to be a significantly
more more godly man and the types of
things that he did when you hear the
stories that he went through of how he
converted he used to be a rebel and how
he came to god and the types of just
hair-raising things that he went through
for
for his faith and and whatnot i would
not put it by him to to have struggled
to want to do something he was not like
a coward he was not he was a brave man
like he was a real a real man
and so for him to be feeling kind of
like there's nothing that he could do in
that situation
being a local you know it's
i can only imagine kind of what what
might have been the motivations behind
that where yeah what do i think i'm
gonna do right and that guy might even
have
be part of a gang or some connections
that could yeah
and we wouldn't know right and so i know
that pastor julius and his wife were
doing things to to help her
right you know like she would eat on
occasion at their house and you know
they would kind of keep an eye on her
and stuff but but beyond that you know
the mom already chose the mom already
chose you know so heartbreaking so you
go to kenya with this mission of helping
your friend build uh this home you're
there for a year you're faced with uh
this
um situation of human trafficking right
right you complete the task of building
the home and now you're back in the
state so where's the connection drawn
between
seeing what's happening in a different
culture country and yeah that's
happening so you know you you start like
okay um
where else does this happen right so you
start reading books and all of a sudden
you know there begins to be kind of
evidence that oh okay well it's
this happens here and this happens there
you just you just start searching for
articles you start searching you know
child brides or you start whatever
you're like you're not going to get
articles on sudan you're going to get
articles all over the world that's right
so you start looking at these things and
all of a sudden it leads you to other
things
and and and you know
before i knew it um i was i was just
going to
to
abolitionist conferences you know
counter trafficking conferences in the
states um
i was volunteering at you know i started
looking at what are some organizations
in in my city i was living in atlanta
and
and i found out well atlanta is one of
the top three cities for trafficking in
the united states
and so i was like wow this is right in
my backyard so
i
you know you you hear statistics you
read statistics i be you know over the
years i've become a bit skeptical of
statistics i think i think that
i'm not sure what their their their you
know
ways of garnering that information is
but
but for me the situation always been
worse than than what statistics purport
them to be
and
statistics just they fail to convey
the personal emotional relational aspect
of it it's just like oh there's 500 000
kids well for me it started with one
i was angry enough just about one
right so i don't need to know that
there's 500 000 kids
right or whatever number
for me like i hadn't been set on this
kind of path because there was one and i
couldn't do anything about one
i i can't even worry about other 499 000
if that was the case
and so you know i started volunteering
and i got involved with um
after going to a few conferences and
volunteering with some different places
there was a particular organization i
believe was called street grace and it
was just it wasn't anything other than
just bringing other people who were
passionate about it and other
organizations within the area kind of
together to a table to discuss
and that's where i got my connections to
other organizations
and then i eventually
met a guy named jeff who i started
with him he was trying he was a lawyer
who was
he felt a passion for it and he
um
wanted to work with
with starting a 24-hour call center for
victims of trafficking there was nothing
that was specific for
victims of trafficking
and he had worked with a place called
the atlanta dream center which started a
project number years before called
princess night and it was basically just
going to the streets where they knew
their trafficking happened right it was
it was an area that was
a lot of a lot of truck stops um a lot
of warehouses um you know some adult
stores and things like that
and
and you know if you go there late at
night you'll see them walking the
streets every every city has a place
where people know that they can go
there's some you know city motels and
some whatever where you can just
you know just just for clarity you're
talking about trafficking or because
what's the difference in like
trafficking and prostitution okay like
uh well
prostitutes primarily are considered
victims of trafficking and the reason
why is because most of them are not
there by the choice
so i i guess we've watched movies like
pretty woman where it kind of tried to
glamorize his prostitution like oh i
want to go be a prostitute in las vegas
or something like that that's not the
reality for a majority of
of people that are there
so a lot of them um were in in bad
situations economically but i would also
say um relationally so there's there's a
history of of
either familial abu abuse or even close
family people who have abused kids or
things like that 95 of the people who
end up on the street have a history of
abuse that doesn't necessarily mean
sexual abuse could be physical abuse
could be
most of it is actually neglect
the parents aren't there yeah
and so that leaves the kid vulnerable
and so a pimp will will know exactly how
to prey upon that they'll go to
neighborhoods where it doesn't
necessarily have to be a poor
neighborhood it could actually be a
fairly affluent neighborhood and they
can go to the mall and they'll just i
mean one of the tactics is to to look at
girls that are in odd numbers because
usually if you have three girls one's
kind of the odd one out you know just
like that third wheel or the fifth wheel
or whatever so they'll look for odd
numbers of girls and they'll categorize
them into three basic categories and
that's like the materialistic girl the
one that's always looking you know the
pretty dresses and the shoes and the
things and just wants that stuff
the one uh that has kind of like the
daddy issues and then the party girl and
so you appeal to each of those in
different ways you know like oh you know
i saw you looking at that and maybe let
me buy that for you whatever you know
those girls they don't they don't
deserve you they're not paying attention
to you but you know and you're so you're
so beautiful you're so whatever just
start this this flattering type of
language you know for the girl that has
the daddy issues that you can kind of
tell has like some emotional baggage
like he'll approach kind of like a
father figure and you know try to
encourage her and say you know i can
fill that void in some ways and then
they reach a point where
where the trust has been built over a
period of time he's bought stuff for her
he's taken her to the clubs to you know
i can get you in through the back door
don't worry about id and stuff like that
just you know he
they're they've become very good at kind
of psychological games and
and and
grooming so they're grooming them over
the process and then what happens is
they'll fall into some made-up situation
where they need help now from her i've
done so much for you
can you now you know after all of the
all after i've done for you when you
just do this one thing one time and they
just need it to happen one time and from
that point it's just it's a spiral
downwards i think that's interesting
because we we hear a lot of stories
about just like you're walking down the
street someone snatches you and then
your section that's right that's i'm not
saying that that doesn't happen it does
happen but there's two there's two ways
yeah i would say i mean i can't say of a
certainty everywhere but i would say in
the states primarily you would have
grooming over over snatching in other
places snatching might be easier you
don't even have to groom anybody but
there's certain places where the poverty
is so that you don't have to do either
you just go up to the parents
and say hey listen i'll make a deal with
you
and and there are places like that south
sudan you know thailand cambodia vietnam
there's certain remote villages in the
middle of the jungles places where you
can just say hey listen you know i'll
you know i'm going to take your daughter
she's going to have a life in the city
here's some money i don't worry about
the rest most pimps will do is have
their um
i don't want to say clients
yeah
they're working they're workers oh
they're workers
okay well no cause sometimes pimps will
have like um the girls go out and then
the girls have to bring back a certain
amount of money but you would still
consider them prostitutes because it's
not like they just have a pimp right on
their neck like they don't they don't so
what what happens is that
once again this is this is how kind of
it works in the states
generally
there's actually there's a hierarchy
that i kind of created of human
trafficking just to kind of help me
conceptualize and kind of what i
experienced over the years but um
normal normal i guess like street pimps
or stuff like that they'll have
something that they call a stable
and they're stable is more or less the
girls that they have within his control
and there's the girl that he kind of
gives special privileges to that is
called the bottom girl and the bottom
girl is kind of like the one that keeps
when they're on the streets keeps the
other girls in check so he doesn't have
to she's like the assistant manager
basically yeah
and so he he you know through
establishing that kind of hierarchy is
able to kind of back off kind of go hang
out with his buddies do whatever and
know that in the morning she's going to
show up with the money
that
that they want and she's going to
maintain her position by continuously
monitoring the other girls and making
sure whatever
but there's also more to it than that
there's there's even even without the
presence of a bottom girl there's other
things that would keep them under
control uh dependency right and that
could be emotional dependency drug
dependency like there's just they
there's there's
i think we sometimes underestimate the
level of
psychological games that go into this
and the ways that we can actually be
broken down yes it's actually there's a
lot of there's a lot of similarities
between even where we are
as christians and them as prostitutes
and i'm probably jumping the gun on that
but um
you're like
how does that work but we'll i'll
probably come to that in a second so so
hold your horses but
um there's also the bond between like
the group of girls so usually if one of
them decides to do something yeah it can
impact i mean just think about it like
where else are you going to go right
like who are you you can't go back to
your family you feel all used up
and you could be beaten if
some like one of them runs yeah you have
all the others it's just kind of like
this like we're in this together even
though
the the levels
yeah the the mentality the the levels of
of of
psychological games is just
it's very complex
and you know i kind of a note
um
there was there was a slave owner
willie lynch you guys heard of lynching
obviously like this big part of american
history william lynch who lynching was
named after was supposedly we don't know
if he was real or not there's assuming
there's a legend whatever but he he has
this manual on how to submit
right like how do you how do you subject
the slave to the the slave masters like
absolute control like breaking of what
so so william lynch apparently he had a
sugar plantation um
in in the caribbean
and he just had great success and people
in the southern plantations were like
teach us your secrets
and so he wrote this manual on how to
how he did it and that manual is
actually what is passed today from pimp
to pimp
and that's what they use wow so so
there's people
black and white wear pimps and they're
using this old slave owner's
manual
to
create new prostitutes
in order to subject people to their so
they're becoming slave masters in a
sense yeah yeah so that's why i said
like in reality like human trafficking
prostitution is kind of like just a
small portion of it's like the tip of
the iceberg kind of thing there's really
a much
bigger thing that's going on and there's
a lot of interconnectedness
so
i don't know if this is the same one but
um there's a i don't yeah i'll just
leave it because i'm not sure but i did
hear of a book
um but it's it's like
they talk about in a way that oh it can
be used in like business or something
like that like it's just completely
removed from its origins it's like how
to just be successful period just read
this book and you'll understand the
human psyche um there there's there's
the 48 laws of power
and that's used a lot as well
um and then you also have sun tzu's
which
uses like how to use deception
to control people to always mislead
people and keep people in the dark and
it's all used by business leaders right
so you know the 48 laws of powers is
more about submission and power and kind
of creating that authority and hierarchy
um suzu's is is more about tactics on
how to
use subversion to to get your way
part of the like a big movement right
now is like sex work is work or whatever
is real work you know like yeah yeah
there's like uh
the young liberals college age they're
they're trying to justify sex work and
it's like but i think a lot of that
mentality is
manipulated anyway through programming
and everything if
and i didn't i didn't touch upon this
but if i were to ask you hypothetically
if you were a slave master what type of
slave would be the best type of slave to
have
submissive wondering
right and this is i know this is a
really hard question
and the conclusion that i could come to
is
is one that wants to be a slave
or one that is convinced that his
slavery his or her slavery is freedom
there you go and so what happens is all
you have to do is you have to change the
mentality because slavery
physical things are used to create a
mental state a mental emotional state
but if the physical can be bypassed and
immediately create the mental emotional
state
then you all of a sudden will have
people that don't think they're slaves
because they haven't been beaten because
they haven't been chained because they
haven't been forced at least not in a
physical sense
but maybe they could be convinced
so that they they think that what
they're doing is their own will but in
reality they're acting according to
someone else's will that's corporate
america i also it's it's the world yeah
yeah so i also watched recently like
this vox news um
kind of like mini documentary of how
yeah they were saying that they wanted
prostitution to be legal because it's
safer for workers because they can
actually go to the authorities when
something bad happens versus like you
reporting it and nobody believing you or
you get put in prison because you're
doing so so that's what they thought
about the red light district in
amsterdam but now if you ask
anybody who's been within within the
netherlands government they will tell
you
that
the red light district is run by
organized crime legally
legal organized right and so what you're
doing is you're you're you're allowing
people who do things illegally to now
come from the underground to
to the open
but they're still the same people it is
tough because both sides end up
benefiting you're trying to help the the
ones who are hurting but right it's
going to be exploited by the people
i mean like
the the if it was underground those guys
still have deals with authorities
whether it's judges or cops or
government officials and now that
they're legal don't tell me those those
relationships disappear that's the same
so even if you have the right to call a
cop because it's legal now
you call a cop and that cop could still
be his friend that judge can still be
his friend
right question about that because okay
so in this country we have the dea right
yeah so if there's a crack house or
maybe someone says a tip that there's
drugs being distributed in such a such
an area yeah the dea steps in and tries
to defuse a situation is there such
agency
or government anything
in regards to human trafficking or
trafficking there was going to be one
there was going to be one so under obama
he started something called the blue
campaign and that was supposed to be a
section under the department of homeland
security
and i was part
our organization was part and i was sent
as a representative
they asked a bunch of organizations from
the united states who were kind of
forerunners in the counter-trafficking
industry and they were saying hey
tell us the government what you need how
this works what we're supposed to do
like you educate us and we felt like oh
this is gonna be great and so we went to
these series of over a period of like
six or more months like meeting with
these guys and having all of these
committees and all that kinds of stuff
that's some level of consultant
and at the end of it we're given the
draft of what they've proposed and it
has nothing to do with anything that any
of us have ever recommended
wow and i remember standing up
at that meeting at the end when they
gave us the first draft and after
reading through it i literally i stood
up
and i said listen
we're in a boat with a massive hole and
water is rushing in and not only are you
not giving anything for us to stop the
hole with you're giving us a cup that
can't even stem the tide of the flow
coming in
and how long ago was this this was in
2011 i believe and it's 2022. it's 2022.
and still nothing not that i'm aware of
i mean there there's an organization but
in terms of like it's still relegated
most most often to police and fbi wow um
so what what
what's being done now like so if someone
wants to be part of the solution someone
is feeling their rage right now like oh
i need to get involved and yes there's
these conventions and that's really
important discussions are being hap like
happening that's important but what are
the fruits of that how can someone get
physically involved in making well you
know what uh that that leads to to a
story that i'm gonna have to bring in
someone else on that that ended up
discovering that with me so i have a
friend who actually had no background in
encounter trafficking and some
experiences that we had together kind of
revealed to us because i
i'll be honest with you we don't know
how to apply practically
it's just theoretical
and and being involved in
counter-trafficking yeah you get to see
a little bit of that and you can't you
know can't deny that it exists or
whatever but it still doesn't mean you
know how to live it practically like how
do i
engage like okay i get it spiritual
warfare but this is very physical to me
right now right like how do i help this
person physically
and um you know the conclusion that i
came over through the years was that
i made it too much of a physical thing
and not enough of the spiritual thing
and so if i could reverse it i would
start spiritually and end physically
rather than start physically and
spiritually but that's not to say that
people can't start
you know involved in physical rescues or
involvement or things like that because
i believe that that god directs us you
know
i learned what i learned today by by
doing things wrong
and and god was merciful in that regard
so i don't want people to be afraid to
step out there and be like i'm going to
make mistakes like yeah you will yeah
you're going to mess stuff up but
but just stick with it because one of
the hardest things to do is just to
continue doing it because you feel
discouraged you feel like i'm not doing
anything and it's very easy to look at
the world and all of a sudden getting
like nothing's happening
nothing's happening like governments
like they're corrupt you know like you
know we had moments where you know we
had friends that were police
and you know we would get
like hey we were sent out on this call
to go rescue you know because you have
to find somebody within 48 hours if
you're missing children or missing
whatever you need to find them out
within 48 hours because if you find them
without that window then the chances
drop considerably right yeah it's almost
whatever so so those first 48 hours are
extremely important and there was times
where we would get friends from from fbi
or gbi georgia bureau investigation or
police or whatever they'd come and
they'd be like talk to us in private and
be like man i'm so frustrated
we were sent out on this and like within
hours we were called by i hire up saying
forget it unbelievable don't follow
don't don't
don't ask questions
just come back
and so you get to see these kinds of
things you get to be in those meetings
where you realize nobody listened to
anything that you said but you also see
progress too you see certain laws
changing you see you know things that
that you know no longer
just protect the pimp and prosecute the
prostitute which was the case when we
first started but we we made progress in
legislation in our local government that
really began to put things into
protection for prostitutes and more
prosecuting towards pimps and clients
people who bought and things like that
but at the end of the day you still
there's still like this battle and you
realize that hey you know the the
corruption goes goes to the top
and so you know i over the years i i
kind of categorized these into into five
categories
one is the low level pimp that's just
like some guy who's just trying to make
a buck right he might have been abused
himself and and what he's doing is just
he's a hurt person hurting other people
he knows you know it's all he knows kind
of thing and you know you might have a
small stable and a couple girls or
whatever three or four girls or
something like that then you got level
two which is kind of like more of a
network you'll have more connections
maybe you'll you'll he'll bribe a cop or
something or or have a connection with a
taxi driver or just you know he's a
little bit more sophisticated right
maybe he'll connect with other pimps and
have something you know he's he's not
green he's not new to the field he's
he's been around for a while
um and and the level of one and two is
primarily where i would say that we
dealt most of the time
level three is when you begin getting
into organized crime you get a little
bit mafia you get you get you know
entire hotels involved um you know if
it's if it's international you'll get
like you know people who are involved
with with maybe people at the airport or
you know bus station
or you know obviously taxi drivers are a
big one restaurants things like that
level four is what i would call kind of
more high-end escorts
um you know kind of the hollywood thing
um the integration of you know
prostitution within the elites of
society
and level five
is
um but many people don't think it exists
but just my thought that it does and
i've had evidence to believe that it
exists is that it's just ritual satanic
worship same thing that you see in the
old testament but people sacrificing
their children do not sacrifice your
children until like do not cause them to
pass through the fire do not do these
types of things that same type of
religions that we think that those are
just relegated to the past i believe
they still exist
not here really i would say that they
exist more wow in first world countries
than in third world countries level one
two and three third world countries
four and five
first world war but places like india
still have
like um temple prostitutes sure sure
sure but that's not the same there's
there's a difference between killing
people though
there's a difference between
prostitution and kidnapping people i see
okay and using them for rights where
they end up dead
that's why i say that's level five i
mean that's some really freaky stuff
yeah and then people be like it doesn't
happen and
we have more than enough evidence to say
that it does
right and so obviously this is not the
scope of this particular conversation
and many of the things that i say are
could to you be claims that you don't
necessarily have to believe and i would
say well you're wise and not believing
somebody's claims immediately so you do
need evidence for all of these things
and so i'm just speaking because i have
the background i can't convey all that
to you and so i'm expecting you to
believe everything that i say but but
take it within a certain context right
we're we're forming a puzzle here like
it's it's hard to always look at a piece
and be like okay that makes sense until
you actually begin to have the whole
picture and all this all of a sudden
within the context of what's really
going on that piece now fits yeah i can
believe that now not because i have
these facts but i can believe it because
it fits in with so many other things
that create this this this picture of
like wow that's really what it is that's
like the point of it that's why it's
existed for so long and and so that's
kind of more of my view yes there are
individual facts and evidences that
point to that and experiences but but
also fits within a larger context of wow
this is
it it doesn't make sense without that
particularly well to deny that it's
basically just like saying the devil
doesn't exist or something in many ways
i mean and so what have what the bible
tells us he's the god of this world he's
the one that offered jesus all the
kingdoms of the world just do this
and um yeah he
he wants you you do this and i'll give
you this well see that's the difference
that's the difference is that that
everything that that jesus
does satan has has a has a counterfeit
for so when you have these old testament
things of people sacrificing their
children to appease the gods it's the
very opposite of what god is like
because satan knew that god would
sacrifice himself
and so there's still sacrifice involved
but rather than you sacrificing yourself
you know greater love has no man than
this that a man laid down his life for
his brother satan's way is you sacrifice
them for me
right so so the mentality is a reversal
you don't sacrifice yourself for others
you sacrifice others for yourself
and so if you want more power you got to
sacrifice more
and so it goes beyond just
at my level you know us plebeians where
we're just kind of like i'm gonna step
on you to get advancement in my job
right i'm gonna i'm gonna malign your
character i'm gonna undermine you i'm
gonna whatever censor you or or make up
stories about you and gossip about you
so i can advance in my career that's
technically i'm sacrificing you for
myself but at the higher levels it
actually turns into more than just that
it turns into
to actually like no i'm going to
sacrifice people
uh and and i know that's that's a pretty
dark subject but yeah um i have two
questions yeah number one if you see
something bad happening to someone and
you don't do anything about it does that
make you partially responsible well
ezekiel tells us that it does
so
what can you do
like if you if you were to see someone
being
trafficked
and you don't do anything about it like
what can you do well it it it really
depends like if i were to see a
prostitute on the street is different
than to see somebody being kidnapped and
forced into a van
like if i saw somebody either being
raped if i saw somebody being like
wrestled down if i saw somebody being
pushed into a van that is an immediate
action that i could take counter to that
right but the problem is that even in in
cases where i had to teach people to
defend themselves and others in issues
of like rape like you would have to say
something like fire
because if you say rape most people will
actually run away because they don't
want to be involved they don't want to
do anything when they see those types of
situations so if you're a person that
wants to see help or get help in that
type of situation let's say it's
happening to you as a woman or even as a
man because it happens to men too
like
for you to actually get somebody to help
you you can't even say rape
because most people will run away you
have to say oh fire why everybody will
run to fire and the moment they see
they're legally responsible they can't
they there's no more deniability right
and so when we see it we we have that
responsibility not because it's legal
but because god has told us to be
responsible
but in a sense of like prostitution
where you see somebody just kind of on
the streets that's a very different case
because that is something that you
actually have to build trust with that
person and that's kind of what we did
with princess knight before we we
started the 24-hour call center is we
had to be on the streets we had to let
them know who we are we had to convince
them that we were different than all of
the other people that met before because
their confidence in people is shot
right and rightfully so they've been
lied to and that's all that they've been
this lied to
and so you have to build that trust and
then you have to say listen
i hope that i've gained your confidence
if you need help
like call this number we'll we'll get
you off the streets and that's the way
that we worked and and you know our
first year we had you know 45 calls
where we i mean 45 rescues calls that
ended up in rescues and the next year we
had 115 and like i think 245 so every
year was virtually doubling
but that was also because of our
presence creating relationships and all
of a sudden other prostitutes were
recommending us saying hey listen
sweetheart if a new girl comes on the
street like hell baby see those guys
over there you can trust them they're
good people so we had prostitutes that
were still like i'm not ready to come
off the street but i'm gonna bring other
girls to you we had pimps that were
doing that wow we had pimps that came
off the street and so you know when
people thinking like there's certain
people beyond redemption don't think
that
that's not your position man i'm serious
just just get off that horse that's not
your position to say that person is
beyond redemption that's not that's not
what you and i can do you be there you
let god decide and if that person comes
to you you make yourself available yeah
right so there's certain times where you
have to act and there's sometimes you
just have to be there
and and it just depends on the situation
so you touched on what could happen or
what the response could be if someone
sees something happening in the act
um you touched on what could happen if
um you see like prostitution and these
things happening human trafficking like
already happening what can someone do as
a preventative measure maybe it is a
parent and they have daughters or even
sons you've asked a question that is
really hard to answer in like
two minutes okay
that is that is really really big
because there's so many things and i'll
be honest with you like i i wouldn't i
don't think i could do it justice in a
short amount of time can we get one
you can do it okay
the the main thing
the main thing that i would say
contributes to people being vulnerable
because like i said 95
of the people that end up on the streets
have a past
of
a vulnerability or abuse
it has to do with satan's attack on the
institution of the family
that's right and so when people say what
is the greatest preventative measure
to
to creating vulnerabilities to to
trafficking i would say a strong family
both parents present or community at
least you know if there's only one
parent yes another community that that
that gets together and supports right uh
there's just way there's you know i get
we live in a world where divorces are
common but the problem is that there's
too many single parents
i'm not justifying divorce in any way
i'm just saying that there's way too
many single parents
and and that's the problem and then the
step parents might not love the kids it
might be abusive and just adds to to the
trauma and then we have a society
obviously where you know i could get on
the whole thing on on on media and and
how
how pimps have been bypassed and now
there's kids wanting to prostitute
themselves and others with no trafficker
or pimp present because it's they've
been fed within their mind that that's
that's how you get ahead yeah yeah and
so like that's just another thing that's
why i don't want to get started on this
i'm just going to go like crazy on you
um but
but there's there's a lot there and and
i want to come back because i want to
bring i want to bring kind of the the
spiritual aspect to it and kind of how
god changed our view of it and that
happened when when i was during uh
working during um
the the super bowl in 2013 in new
orleans and new orleans already is a
city with with some shady stuff going on
open witchcraft
um you know lots of lots of things that
you know
you walk down the french quarter and
there's
i mean there's just clubs with straight
up just posters of pornography just
right there and mardi gras mardi gras
and all that kind of stuff we were there
during the pre mardi gras party so they
were having a pre mardi gras party
preceding the the the super bowl so this
is very dark like you could feel like
if you ever like walk into a place where
you feel like just the atmosphere is
very oppressive very dense
there's something
weighty there and i don't know you just
feel uncomfortable it was like that 24 7
but it was like really really bad um we
were up until three or four at night we
were calling we were calling numbers of
of pimps and the way that we did it is
we went through craigslist and back
pages we knew what to look for we were
looking for numbers that were not
louisiana numbers numbers that came from
out of state but were advertising
themselves kind of for companionship
within louisiana so there was an
interesting trafficking case which we
could submit to the fbi we were calling
these numbers we were trying to get see
if we'd if it was a pimp we would hang
up if it was a girl we'd talk to her
some girls would bring themselves and so
we'd like hey you know why you're here
you know can you know
try to just talk to her out of it we
ended up going to a lot of these clubs
talking to the bouncer saying hey listen
we brought kits for for the girls that
we know that they're working in the bars
and clubs but we know that there's a
whole lot more going on than just that
and you'd be surprised how many bouncers
and club owners we met that were like oh
dude thank you for being here man those
guys are going through rough times
and just you know our girls were able to
go in there
and kind of give out these kind of care
kits just to kind of be like hey listen
we're praying for you
you know
we're thinking of you um this is for you
and just you know girls crying be like
yeah you know this is really hard for me
i you know i'm kind of here because of
my situation and stuff like that so
there's people that are there of their
own volition
right they're involved in that kind of
thing but but
you're gonna be like one percent that
say i want to be there after they've
been there for a while
after they've been in for a while yes
you'll get people who'd be like yeah
it's glamorous let me show up and then
after some years the reality hits you
and you're like whoa this is not this is
that
it was to be
and so anyway after that after the
situation i i honestly hit a low
spiritually like i it was just after
years of doing it i was started in 2010
end of 2010 beginning of 2011 with the
call center and by this 2013 three years
later of doing this all the time
getting the calls rescuing girls have
girls disappear going to these events
and all that kinds of stuff it just
starts
doing investigations seeing how
prevalent it is hearing the testimonies
of cops kind of like who can't do
anything because they've been told not
to do anything
like all this stuff just begins stacking
and i just i
three some years and i was i was done
and i said lord i can't do this anymore
like my spirituality was like shot
and um and you know it came to my
attention that the following year would
be fifa world cup in brazil 2014.
and i had a decision to make i said am i
going to quit now
or
you know
am i going to do something knowing what
happened here during super bowl am i
going to go to world cup and do
something about that
and
um
i began doing a little bit of research
because for me it's always like let's
find out what's going on you know it was
like 262 points of trafficking on one
major highway that connects to northern
brazil to southern brazil that have
already been identified half a million
kids that are supposedly being sold
into into as prostitutes
number of of children that are supposed
to go missing from the slums or favelas
um during during leading up to the world
cup was said to go by 300 percent
you know because of the world cup like
this these are government statistics and
they don't and they're trying to make
things look pretty because they're
trying to bring in investors right the
brazilian government is trying to paint
the prettiest picture they possibly can
to bring in investors because fifa is
huge this is their economic opportunity
or discouragement you want to discourage
people with stuff like you know so they
they ended up you know trying to hide as
much putting kids in motels so they
wouldn't be on streets and all this
kinds of stuff you know create an
underground where you can go online and
somebody from germany can basically like
show up in brazil for the world cup and
already have a taxi a hotel and
restaurants that are involved
and he nobody will ever know that he did
anything because the hotel that he's
staying at that's where the kids are
being held and the restaurant that he's
eating at the taxi driver that's taking
him there they all know
and so it's all part of like this
network where you can show up and on the
face like he's just a tourist
right nobody knows that everybody's
staying at that hotel is sleeping with
kids
like you know and and like so so they
they really pushed it underground and
yet the statistics were still horrifying
right the systems were still horrifying
and i said listen you know if
if this is going on like would i be able
to live with myself as a man knowing i
did nothing
and and a verse came to my mind and it
was you know first john 3 16 and 17. you
know by this we perceive the love of god
and that he gave his life for us
if he gave his life for us we also ought
to give our life for others whoever has
this world's good and sees his brother
in need and does nothing shuts up his
bowels of compassion how does the love
of god dwell in him and my answer was
well it doesn't
and so do i want to say that god's love
has no place in me
am i going to say that i don't have the
love of god at all like yeah i get it
i'm not feeling good spiritually i don't
want to do this right now i'm just tired
i'm burnt out i can't do this but am i
am i willing to say
you know what love of god does not have
even an inch of space in me i said no i
can't do that i don't want to shut that
and so i said all right i don't know how
i'm going to get there i'm going to do
it
but i don't want to push past that point
because you're you're you're pushing
past your feelings of i don't know
inadequacy or like detachment from god
and you're like i i have this duty yeah
this passion in my heart i'm gonna do it
anyway yeah just how you know how do you
well i was trying to figure that out i
was like is anybody from brazil right
does anybody know people in brazil it's
like seeking communities yeah and i was
also trying to find people who would be
willing to go but but i didn't have
anybody you know and i don't blame
anybody it just makes sense like some
random guy shows up and says hey listen
i'm going to brazil to work counter
trafficking like i don't know who you
are i mean it sounds good but i mean so
i'm not blaming anybody for that i'm
just saying that it ended up in kind of
like and i'm glad that it did
because that's what what god was able to
bring the most out of was when he he
kind of stripped back all my dependency
on these types of things because for for
these years you know when when i was in
south sudan i couldn't do anything by
myself but now all of a sudden i've
grown a dependency on the organizations
i was part of a big organization i was i
was being you know asked by governments
to to go teach at schools and and you
know consult you know people in high
positions of department of homeland
security and and we were working with
with governors and senators to to
legislate stuff like all of a sudden you
begin feeling like you're part of
something right and god is like okay
back up you're still too dependent on
that i need you to come back to me
and so i think god and even who's
stripping my dependence on the church as
well he's like yeah i want you to be a
part of the church i want you to work
with the church but i want you to work
with me first
and in many ways you know that's that's
what he was doing and so i
you know i i bought my ticket i showed
up in brazil i i went to a brazilian
church in atlanta they some nice person
was saying hey listen i've got a cousin
that lives in sao paulo you can stay at
her house
and so she called up her cousin he's
like yeah you can have that guy stay at
my house so i showed up at her house i
was there for about a month do you speak
portuguese no i didn't i do now
i didn't then
i knew like two or three words
i didn't even have money
after i bought my ticket i had like i
have a few hundred bucks i had like 800
bucks when i arrived in brazil to last
for six seven months us dollars us
dollars yeah so i'm like how am i gonna
survive for like six or seven months
with 800 bucks god it doesn't matter how
cheap the place is right it doesn't
matter how cheap the place is and so i
ended up you know a month later after
all of these like local connections that
i thought okay i can't depend on on asi
and gyc or whatever i was i'll be honest
with you i was like a little frustrated
like okay i'll just go to other
organizations and they left me too i'm
like oh great like nobody's there even
the people that are there aren't there
the people that are in brazil on the
streets are still not there they didn't
want to do anything at least not with me
and uh so i just kind of was like oh
there's there's no point of being
frustrated
so i went out of the house
and i just started walking i saw
somebody that looked like they were
having a bad day i'm like well i'm
having a bad day too
and so i'm like maybe i should pray for
this person i have no idea where that
thought came from i'm a doer i'm not a
i'm not a spiritual person i'm a man i'm
gonna build something i'm gonna rescue
some some ladies i'm gonna be a hero and
like that the god was trying to take
that from me
so yeah i i just i need to get out of
the house and so i saw somebody that
that
was not having a good day and i was like
man i need to pray for this person and i
just didn't speak portuguese it's still
you know the person that i was their
house that i was staying at they wanted
to learn english and then here i was
trying to practice portuguese and they
were trying to practice english so they
didn't work out for me
uh and trying to learn portuguese so it
was there for a month and still not able
because you know if
if i knew portuguese then me as a
depressed person would be qualified to
go give counsel to this other depressed
person on how to get out of depression
um but i'm glad i didn't
and god just gave me no other option
than just to pray for this person i did
and uh you know and talk to them i just
saw them and i prayed for them and i
walked a little bit more and i saw
another person and i was like man
i pray for this person too so i did and
i walked through an area that i knew
from my experience was
shady and there's a lot of
you know flags that let me know that
something was going on here that wasn't
quite right and
i started praying for this place and
before i knew it i was walking for five
hours
and praying
and i come back and i'm refreshed
yeah that's how it works i'm looking at
my watch and i'm like what
and then i realized i also went to the
part of town that my host said don't go
don't walk through this area
and i noticed that people were staring
at me like
there was something about me that was
out of place and i don't i look
brazilian like i fit in just fine
anywhere in brazil but
um
yeah that's maybe the way i walk or was
dressed or
i don't know but
people were looking at me and uh
and i realized five hours had passed and
i was like okay
i get it
you you were trying to to take back all
my dependencies and all these things you
want me
just to walk with you and doing
something that only you and i can do
together
i said all right i'll make a deal with
you
um i'm going to go to all 12 cities that
are hosting the world cup
and i'm going to walk through as many
slums that i possibly can
around as many neighborhoods and
even around the perimeter of the cities
i'm going to walk around the stadiums
because i remember what it was like
being at at the
super bowl i'm going to pray for the
stadiums i'm going to pray for these
places and and all you need to do is
show me the exact people you want me to
talk to you you got to teach me
portuguese you got to help me with money
you got to bring me somebody because i'm
not going to do it alone i'm just one
more other person you when you walk and
pray like it's good to have
one other person a prayer party build
each other up yeah and so that's kind of
where where that next chapter of the
story began and where god began to peel
back kind of like the veil of things
that i had missed up until that point
wow wow and we're gonna hear that story
in a different episode
looking forward to that thank you so
much alex thank you for all this i mean
it's such a wealth of knowledge someone
who is has sat through this and heard
maybe they have a friend that came to
mind that needs help or maybe they just
want to get involved or maybe they want
more information and our show isn't
enough yeah what resources can they well
if you have somebody if you have
somebody that that you know is within
the southeast and i don't know how much
it's spread because i haven't been in
contact with them but out of darkness if
you go out of darkness.org that was the
organization that i worked with years
back and the call line i know is still
operational we still have the 24-hour
hotline and the rescue center and all
that kinds of stuff and they work
together with the atlanta dream center i
know they're still very involved so if
you're in the southeast that's that's
really a primary resource if you know
somebody who who's in that issue or or
even if you want to to be connected with
other people in that world it's a really
good place to just because they work
with multiple organizations and they
they
they build relationships and and this
world wouldn't exist without
relationships between this there's less
competition you know it's not like
you're working there we're working here
it's kind of like no this is a big
problem we need to work together and so
that's one thing that i think you'll
find in
once you get involved anywhere else i'm
afraid i'm not as familiar with it you
would just
it comes with just
creating some level of familiarization
like just awareness awareness and and
you'll notice that once you meet
somebody the world is very small they'll
know somebody else or some other thing
and then that's the way that i learned
it it's just i started going to
different places and then i learned
which ones i wanted to work with and
which ones i didn't
and yeah i didn't memorize all of
america's but i wish i had kind of a
list of all of them but i i feel bad in
in giving a list if i didn't work with
them personally
because then i couldn't recommend them
because i will say that there are
purposeful organizations that have
started up in the name of jesus or as a
christian whatever to say that they're
there to help but are purposefully there
to
re-exploit people
um
and it's it's another just kind of issue
in and of itself but but you do have to
be careful because
uh as we'll learn later we're messing
with with people that that satan thinks
are his property
and he doesn't take lightly to people
who step on his on his territory and try
to take what's his so
um there's a level of caution but but
also a level of hope because i think god
will
will make you more dependent on him than
almost any other situation
and prayer is powerful oh yeah you're
going to find out that even as a
stubborn man like me
prayer became the thing
that i was like man
but yeah i know god god had to slap me
upside my good old head well with that
everyone
i encourage you to get on the app app
awareness prevention and prayer
utilize all three of those actually in
fact can you if you made it to this part
of the video blow up the comment section
with those three letters app awareness
prevention and prayer get you know
people curious oh what are they talking
about we're going to continue on with
this conversation and if you're
interested we have episodes coming up
talking about human trafficking talking
about the stories of alex and his
partner and
and possibly how you can get involved or
get more resources thank you so much for
watching please continue in prayer with
us for the people within this human
trafficking
what experience or problem
and also those fighting against it and
we pray just a prayer protection over
those people who are not in that world
yet that that
the heavenly host will prevent the
devil's attacks and getting people
involved in this in this lifestyle so
again thank you so much for watching
links to our social media platforms to
support us on patreon our website and
our t-shirts will all be in the
description below and we'll see you next
week on led live bye
[Music]
foreign